[Music]
if you grow up in Mexico you grew up
going to bakeries every day the smells
and the flavors just the experience to
pick the pan dulce and to pick the bread
my mom didn't like that I grabbed the
tray and the tongs because I used to
pile the tray up high that's something
that we wanted to replicate here in the
US recording I met in Business School we
actually were from the same city in
Mexico we hadn't met until we both were
at Stanford when we moved to LA we saw
that that tradition was there among the
Latino communities but there wasn't
necessarily a place that reflected
exactly what it was like to be home
that's the beginning of this idea we are
in our store in Highland Park northeast
of downtown Los Angeles very dense
Hispanic community working-class
neighborhood there is a lot of activity
from very early on in the morning you
see people coming and going we've always
tried to hire locally and we make sure
our products are made from scratch my
favorite items on the menu
the Concha which is the traditional
sweet bread we have breakfast tacos in
the morning we make an H at a latte
which oh yeah that's pretty good over
ice when we first opened we learned a
lot by just being at the first location
pretty much all the time we actually we
would sleep there if you're thinking of
doing your own business
there's never gonna be a better time to
do it then right after you graduate the
opportunity cost of just deciding to go
for it is the lowest it's ever gonna be
some of the classes that I remember from
the GSB performance leadership the
Entrepreneurship classes were terrific
they have a lot of lessons and teachings
about how to run an organization and how
really it comes down to building
effective teams what are the gifts of
going to the GSB is the alumni community
some of the advisors of our company are
GSB alumni so most if not all of our
success is due to them to create company
culture is daily things it's with the
way we act not only with our employees
but with our customers with our
pliers I derive the most pleasure from
people you really have to enjoy people
to be in the restaurant business that
gives me great joy I really like going
our stores and just talking to our staff
it's actually a little dangerous because
you can spend the whole day just talking
to our team nobody goes angry into a
bakery which is another plus of being in
this business
[Music]